one thing the bite Administration wants
you to know is that it takes enforcing
the law very seriously it is a defender
of the rule of law we are told and it's
especially devoted to the law when it
comes to gun crime supposedly this is
something that Biden takes very
seriously in fact Biden's doj proudly
promotes its handling of gun cases on
its website as part of a much larger
initiative which is supposedly intended
to combat gun violence they want you to
believe that lying on federal gun forms
is a very serious crime that's why
earlier this year the ATF put out a
statement entitled Federal prosecutors
aggressively pursuing those who lie in
connection with firearm transactions
it's also why a few weeks ago Democrats
in Congress held hearings featuring
anti-gun activists like Rob Wilcox and
that hearing was derailed though when a
congressman asked Wilcox a simple and
obvious question
why isn't Hunter Biden going to prison
given that he lied on a federal Forum
about his drug use and his Navy
discharge to obtain a firearm Democrats
in the hearing room didn't like that
question very much watch
if a person lies on form 4473 and a user
and is a user of unlawful drugs
um
you can get between five to ten years
for that is that correct is that my
understanding
no I believe Congress changed the uh
sentence uh last Congress uh what is
that sentence now up to 15 up to 15
years uh why hasn't Hunter Biden been
prosecuted for the crime that he
committed
I'm not aware of the facts of that case
and can't comment on it
okay who do we talk to to see why this
uh case is not being prosecuted I mean
he said very clearly in his book that he
used drugs he had uh gun aegon at least
a point of order Mr chairman
totally irrelevant and not your million
to this person sir he's got his he's got
his five minutes go ahead continue
okay
I understand why um you do not want Mr
Wilcox to answer that question it's very
clear why you don't want because there's
a dual system of justice in America
that's what's going on right now and
everybody's talking about it across
America there's two standards of justice
that are
um that are going on
two standards of Justice he says and
well he was proven right of course by
now you've probably heard how the Biden
doj managed to square this circle
yesterday after a five-year criminal
investigation the doj announced that
unlike Ray and Juan and Eddie Hunter
will not go to prison for a year for
lying on a federal gun form in fact he
won't even spend a day in prison
insteader Hunter Biden will go into a
diversion program
and that's remarkable not just because
it's an obviously unfair result but also
because diversion programs like that
according to the doj's own guidelines
are unavailable to any defendant who has
ever brandished a firearm while
committing a felony
and as National Review has reported
publicly available videos from Hunter
Biden's laptop quote show him
brandishing the weapon while high on
crack cocaine which is also a felony
needless to say hunter Biden was never
charged with brandishing his firearm or
smoking crack he also wasn't charged
with reckless endangerment after his
handgun wound up in a trash bin across
the street from a high school even
though that seems like a pretty big
public safety risk
Senator Mike Lee noted that prosecutors
could have easily brought these cases
and probably many others quote evidence
supported other charges that would have
rendered him presumptively ineligible
for diversion
but the doj buried all of that the doj
also LED Hunter Biden off the took on
tax evasion he's getting no jail time
for failing to pay taxes for two years
several former assistant U.S attorneys
including Andrew Weissman and Renato
Mariotti
think that all this checks out quote
these charges are rarely brought Mary
Audi wrote on Twitter yesterday he said
he added quote if anything it looks like
Hunter Biden received harsh treatment
well it took all of like five minutes
for journalist Mike cernovich to debunk
that by citing Renato mariotti's own
work including the time Mariotti pursued
a five-year prison sentence for
defendants who failed to pay taxes on
less than two million dollars in income
and that was not an unusual case the
typical sentence for tax fraud offenders
according to the doj's on statistics is
over 16 months in prison
and these are often people who unlike
Hunter Biden didn't abuse The public's
trust by selling a politician's
influence overseas
now we're not going to spend any more
time on the hypocrisy that's on display
in Hunter Biden's case we're not going
to go into how on his first day in
office Joe Biden put a law partner of
Hunter Biden's defense attorney in
charge of the Criminal Division of the
doj you can spend all day talking about
stuff like that
the special treatment couldn't be more
obvious so there's no point belaboring
it like we all see it
what's interesting what's really
interesting though is that if you dig a
Little Deeper
the story is much bigger than Hunter
Biden indeed it's much bigger than
politics
and if you doubt that watch this report
from ABC's top Washington correspondent
pay close attention to how the reporter
contradicts himself in real time
apparently without realizing it watch
these issues of conflict of interest and
and playing off his name in the Biden
family name will be investigated uh by
by Congress by republicans in Congress
um and the issue is not going away but
doesn't this show Carl that Biden is not
in the pocket of the doj
I mean yes and again it depends on so
how do you look at it do you look at it
you say look they prosecuted anyway his
son now has a criminal record yes that
shows uh that it would seem to show
there was no interference he didn't pull
the plug on the investigation he didn't
order his attorney general to pull the
plug on the investigation but when
Republicans will say is that this didn't
look at the bigger more serious
allegations there are significant
concerns about Hunter Biden's business
dealings you know he has that the
contract that he had uh with with the
Ukrainian Energy company also his
business dealings in China I mean one of
the details that we reported earlier
they were looking into that's just so
strange he was given Hunter Biden was
given a 2.8 carat diamond uh from a a
Chinese business associate I mean what
what what's it all about we don't know
now if you can filter out the dumb
talking points from The View lady about
how this totally vindicates the doj then
that's actually a fascinating clip the
senior Washington correspondent at ABC
News Begins by explaining that there's
no evidence whatsoever that the Biden
family is corrupt but he ends the
segment by admitting there's something
fishy about that fat Diamond that
somehow found its way from China into
Hunter Biden's possession picture the
perfect Summer Night the warm Summer
Breeze on your face as you lounge and
your favorite chair outside the grill
sizzling with Juicy Burgers the aroma of
the food is irresistible your mouth
Waters as you wait for it to be cooked
to Perfection now imagine what this
perfect summer night would look like if
you went to turn on the grill and your
propane tank was empty that's where my
friends at cinch come in and they can
save the day for you cinch is a propane
grill tank Home Delivery Service they
deliver propane tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule does not
require any long-term commitment or
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home you can track the order
on the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you're grilling for the sweet baby gang
camping with your family or lighting up
your fire pit on a cold summer night
whatever it is cinches propane delivery
service ensures you have the fuel you
need to make the most of every moment
and every summer night go online to
cinch.com or download their app to order
new customers can get their first tank
exchange for just ten dollars with promo
code Walsh that's
c-y-n-ch.com promo code Walsh this is a
limit time offer and you must live
within a cinch service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer for details
Congress once again allowed itself to be
pushed into appease in the
administration and raising the debt
ceiling to the 79th time Paving the way
for continued Reckless spending and
further devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings Times
Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold they're who I buy my gold
from so so do thousands of other concern
Savers Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
it's very easy to do when currencies
fail gold is a safe haven how much more
time does a dollar have ask yourself
that well you could protect your savings
with gold Birch gold has an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
and thousands of happy customers text
Walsh to 989898 and get your free info
kit on gold today again text Walsh to
later he goes on to see that it's weird
that Biden was making tens of thousands
of dollars a month for a no-show job at
a Ukrainian Energy company and selling
his paintings for ludicrous sums of
money to unknown foreign buyers Etc
now put aside whatever you think of the
politics of all this maybe you love
Hunter Biden for some reason I don't
know ask yourself this though what's the
effect on millions of Americans watching
a news report as incoherent and poorly
conceived as that one it's not just
fraudulent reporting it's obviously
fraudulent reporting even if you're a
die-hard Democrat that has to resonate
with you for the wrong reasons it's not
just that the doj is cutting the
president's son a break what we're
seeing what's now undeniable
is that the media apparently is so inept
that they can't even lie about it
properly even ABC's highest ranking
correspondent in Washington just can't
pull it off to save his life
this gets to a much broader issue which
is a lot bigger than Hunter Biden and
that that issue is the level of trust
Americans have in the core institutions
of this country
every poll shows that the trust is
plummeting and it's not hard to see why
everywhere you look you're being
subjected to propaganda that would make
North Korean State media blush
they're treating you like you're a
complete idiot it's Relentless just
hours and just hours after the doj
announced that 100 Biden won't face any
punishment for violating federal law
numerous federal laws the Pentagon
revealed that yet another accounting
error means that we get to we get to
spend six billion dollars more in
Ukraine
because of an accounting error
imagine that
on top of that also on the very same day
that the the doj announced Hunter Biden
wouldn't go to prison we learned that
the plan is to put Donald Trump on trial
prior to the 2024 election
how is CNN covering that well they ran
this headline quote another historic
week in the investigation and
prosecution of Donald Trump
contrast that with another CNN Headline
from this week on the same kind of
prosecution happening in Russia quote
Russian opposition leader faces decades
behind Barr as new trial starts
translation it's good when we throw our
opposition leaders in jail it's bad when
Russia does it
well if it's hard to believe that
anyone's falling for this anymore that's
because no one is falling for it anymore
at least very few people
every major institution in this country
now flaunts the Norms they pretended for
so long to care about
and that matters because the quote
unquote democratic system that the left
pretends to deeply cherish
doesn't work
if the people lose all trust and faith
in the system itself if nobody believes
any of this or believes in any of this
it all falls apart
people notice
when the authorities imprisoned Good
Samaritans like Daniel Penny even as
arsonists and rapists go free
they noticed when the doj sends a SWAT
team to raid the home of a father who
protected his child from an abortion
clinic volunteer while totally failing
to investigate attacks on Christian
pregnancy centers
breakdowns and Trust often begin in the
political world in response to obvious
hypocrisy like this but the harm
transcends the political world very
quickly
pretty soon you have no Norms left of
any kind whatsoever
for years we've been witnessing in slow
motion the destruction of any Integrity
in the fields of medicine and Public
Health
and this week very publicly it came to a
head now we're told that vaccine
scientists shouldn't debase themselves
by debating Skeptics on Joe Rogan's
podcasts you know you have guys like Tom
Nichols and others people in The
Establishment media they've been arguing
for days that the The credibility of the
medical field would be diminished if
experts engaged in these kinds of
spectacles
started lowering themselves to the point
of debating non-experts on podcasts
but the medical Field's credibility is
already diminished to the point of
non-existence
like nobody trusts it anymore
that's what happens when you forcibly
inject the drug in the millions of
people's bodies while lying about its
efficacy
and when you castrate and sterilize
children while claiming that it's a
life-saving procedure
it's what happens when the entire
medical field solemnly declares out of
nowhere that men can get pregnant
the guy who's refusing to debate RFK Jr
on Joe Rogan's podcast is named Peter
Hotes he's supposedly a preeminent
vaccine expert the media tells us but on
every major issue concerning vaccines in
covet over the past two years hotels
hasn't just been wrong he's been crazy
in April of 2021 for example he wrote in
a nature magazine that anti-vaccine
groups in the United States are linked
to Russia and need to be shut down quote
the United Nations and the highest
levels of government must take direct
even confrontational approaches with
Russia and move to dismantle
anti-vaccine groups in the United States
and back in June of 2020 Hotes appeared
on MSM MSNBC to explain why it's okay to
protest for BLM in the middle of a
pandemic he said quote it's not so
simple to just say that protests will
bring back covid he said he added that
quote structural racism causes Three
Times Higher covid-19 death rates in the
African-American population
hotels wasn't the only scientist to say
that at the time dozens of Public Health
experts agreed Jennifer news new zoa a
Johns Hopkins epidemiologist wrote that
quote In This Moment the public health
risks of not protesting to demand an end
to systemic racism greatly exceed the
harms of the virus
abrar Quran a physician at Brigham and
Women's Hospital wrote while I have
voiced concerns that protests risk
creating more outbreak breaks the status
quo wasn't going to stop kova 19 either
now remember Americans remember all of
this they remember when the buy
Administration nationalized all of
America's rental properties in the name
of Public Health they remember the
demands that we wear cloth masks and
airplanes
and that our children wear masks for
eight hours in school every day
even after everyone admitted that cloth
masks don't do anything
and it's precisely because Americans
remember all of this that they won't
want Peter Hotes going anywhere near an
actual debate
he can go on MSNBC where it's safe
on MSNBC you can talk about how
protesting lockdowns is bad while
protesting the police is good
no one's going to challenge him there
what's important to recognize is that
Peter Hotes is a symptom of a much
larger institutional rot which is now
being reinforced by virtually every
major medical school in this country
last year Wake Forest defended a medical
student who admitted to stabbing a
patient from mocking her pronoun pin
they didn't expel her
in fact she's going to graduate soon
and Wake Forest is not the exception
here's what medical school looks and
sounds like these days let's know this
we enter the profession of Medicine with
appreciation for the opportunity to
build on the scientific and humanistic
achievements of the past we also
recognize the acts and systems of
Oppression affected in the name of
medicine we take this oath of service to
begin building a future grounded in
truth restoration and Equity to fulfill
medicine's capacity to liberate I
promise to take care of my future
patients by engaging in dialogue
listening to their lived experience and
tailoring my recommendations to their
unique circumstances
I acknowledge the past and present
failures of medicine to abide by us
obligation to do no harm and affirm the
need to address systemic issues in the
institutions I uphold I promise to
critically examine the systems and
experiences that impact every person's
health and ability to receive care
it's medical school for you makes you
feel very good if you're going into
surgery you know this week or something
doctors are taking these maoist Oaths
because they now believe ideology is
more important than patient care every
day they abandon another scientific
principle on the altar of wokeism
no matter what effect it has on the
patients here's the latest example now
the American Medical Association is
telling doctors that body mass index or
BMI is a racist concept
you know it's it's racist to to tell
people about BMI or tell them keep their
BMI down that's going to cause a lot of
deaths from diseases like hypertension
and diabetes but they don't care
again the public isn't stupid people
have noticed all this it's why they
don't trust the medical field anymore
that's why they don't trust the justice
system
that's why they don't trust Academia the
media the government
trust in our fundamental institutions
has never been lower
and it's all the fault not of conspiracy
theorists but of the actual actions of
these institutions themselves
if civilization starts coming apart at
the seams
it's not going to be because of alleged
conspiracy theorists like Alex Jones or
whoever it'll be because of the people
and institutions that made the
conspiracy theorists right
about nearly everything
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code walls
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there